all right let's talk about the Big Daddy
of all things related to cognitive
optimization and that is sleep if I were
going to say the two most important
things that you can do to optimize your
cognition is sleep and eat right those
are the big ones but sleep is the one
that will impact you the fastest you
could mess up your diet for a day two
days maybe even a week before it really
starts to hammer you but man you miss
one night's sleep and there is a
catastrophic Cascade of biological
problems that will present themselves
rapidly so somebody that gets I think
less than six hours of sleep a night
shows the same kind of blood glucose
response as somebody who's pre-diabetic
so that gives you an idea of missing
only part of one night's sleep can have
that kind of massive cellular impact so
being incredibly thoughtful about
getting your sleep is super important
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because when I started my
first business I really struggled to
believe myself I was making 300 bucks a
month and quit on my business partner
and the thing that saved me was watching
the stories successful entrepreneurs
they gave me strategies as well as hope
and belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's Master the basic
fundamentals of life and success enjoy
[Music]
as somebody who loves hustle porn and
being hardcore and working an amazing
amount
I do all of that with precious little
negative impact to my sleep I won't say
that it never happens especially not
since I've gotten into nfts it is there
has been some wobble in my perfect sleep
record
um but it's really minor and the reason
that I do that is to me being tired is a
unique ring of hell I do not understand
people who are prepared to go their
entire lives fatigued it makes
everything worse your ability to enjoy
your life goes down you're likely to
being depressed goes way up your
likelihood of having metabolic
disturbances goes way up there there's
just so many things go wrong and then of
course the most traumatically impacted
is your ability to think clearly and
think quickly if you've ever gone even
one night with bad sleep let alone two
or three nights you can feel yourself
declining rapidly in performance in fact
if you take somebody that hasn't gotten
any sleep and put them in a car they
have the same sort of delays that
somebody who's intoxicated has so the
impacts on cognition cannot be
overstated so
be very careful if you're trying to be
at your best and really perform at an
elite level the thing that you must do
is get sleep so make sure that you're
prioritizing your sleep now how do we do
that how do we get sleep done in a high
quality way number one is you want to
make sure that you're sleeping in a
completely dark environment so no Night
Lights hopefully no even like charging
lights or things like that now one way I
do to make myself absolutely bulletproof
not only do I have blackout curtains but
I sleep with the blankets completely
over my head now admittedly it didn't
start for reasons of light pollution but
now as I get older I'm actually grateful
and have my whole life I've had this
pattern of sleeping with the blankets up
over my head which I know for some
people is a just nightmare scenario but
for me it's like
I mean if I'm honest it's like sleeping
in a womb it's just to be completely
encased is so wonderful and it makes me
feel so relaxed absolutely incredible uh
and then the other thing that I do is I
use white noise and so to make sure that
there are no little noises that are
going to wake me up in the middle of the
night I have white noise basically
sounds like a fan
um but from a little machine that plays
that consistent sound and that helps me
sleep incredibly well and then because
my mind is so frequently in problem
solving mode what I've found is that
about 30 minutes before I go to bed I
switch into narrative mode and so I'm
going to be reading a book I use Audible
but I'm going to be listening to a book
that shifts my mind out of problem
solving mode into narrative mode and
then if I wake up in the middle of the
night I keep next to me three pairs of
iPod Pros so that I can put them in I
listen to the book it makes sure that I
don't go into problem solving mode that
I can can stay there in narrative mode
and I turn the volume down just to the
point where a little bit of pressure on
my ear is required to hear them
perfectly and so I'll put that bit of
pressure listen to the story and then as
I fall asleep that pressure comes off my
ear and now I can barely hear it and I
fall right back to sleep now I will give
you the advanced tip which is don't pick
an audiobook that has a bunch of murder
in it because then you wake up to the
narrator screaming and yelling and that
was waking me up so I had to learn the
hard way that there's a certain type of
book that's a good engaging story but
doesn't have narration where you know
there's yelling and screaming at any
point in the story and yeah the last
thing that I will say about my sleep is
that I go to bed at the same time every
night which is 9 pm I treat it like a
religion I go to bed every night at that
time sometimes a few minutes earlier if
I can convince Lisa
and then the second part of that is that
I don't set an alarm so I haven't set an
alarm for the last you know 16 17 years
at this point so trust me you can do
amazing incredible things in your life
without needing to set an alarm I get as
much sleep as I need now I don't have
kids so that is no doubt a big part of
how I'm able to maintain that but the
more that if you do have kids you can
sleep closer to their sleep rhythms to
make sure that you're getting as much
sleep as you need and let me tell you if
I had kids and I needed to go to bed at
7 pm I would go to bed at 7 pm so I'm
gonna go to bed at whatever time I need
to in order to get all the sleep that I
need if you need nine hours get nine
hours your brain shrinks in the middle
of the night which basically the
inflammation is going down so that the
glial system can flush everything out
get rid of any toxins that might be
building up in the system get rid of the
amyloid plaques which are very present
in people that have Alzheimer's probably
doesn't cause Alzheimer's but
nonetheless lets you know that it's
doing some thing that we don't
necessarily want sticking around and I
said the glial system and I think I mean
the lymphatic system somebody will have
to fact check me on that because I'm
actually not sure which but the brain
shrinks nonetheless and allows you to
clear out that system
so being very thoughtful to get as much
sleep as you need so that you can enjoy
your life
so that on a biological cellular level
that you're able to run all your
processes so that you're able to do all
the memory consolidation all the things
that go along with the ancillary effects
to sleeping and then making sure that
you're able to think
as clearly sharply and quickly as
possible and all of those things come
down to the quality of your sleep
quality of your diet
the quality of your exercise and your
ability to manage your psychological
life which we can do most easily through
meditation
so
that in a bundle my friends is how you
take care of yourself cognitively to
make sure that you can deliver an elite
level of performance day after day week
after week month after month year after
year rule number two is build
self-esteem with Bob Proctor what would
you say are some deciding factors that
can help someone with their self-esteem
because you and I are very similar where
my childhood I didn't I didn't have much
confidence in myself or esteem because I
was in the bottom of my class in school
because I was you know had tutors and
special needs classes because I just
wasn't able to understand and comprehend
that well and felt awkward and Goofy in
my life what are some some things you
think people that in their teens or even
in their 40s and 50s who don't have
confidence yet one of the things we can
be doing differently to gain confidence
to build self-esteem because I think
this is one of the key factors of
successes believing in yourself it
doesn't matter if the world believes in
you if you don't believe in you yeah
what can we start to do to change that
well I think person has to start to
study themselves
most people know very little about
themselves they think they're their body
you're not a body you have a body
and you have a marvelous mind
and
when I first started to study this I
thought you know
study in the mind that's for
psychiatrists psychologists behavioral
scientists
and the man that told me he said no it's
not he says that's for anybody that's
for little kids
and so I think as we start to understand
something about our mind
and something about our higher faculties
see we're all programmed to live through
our senses we go about what we see here
smell taste touch
well I've got a little dog at home that
you see here smell taste touch
all the animals in the world they're
they're completely at home in their
environment they blend in
they operate by instinct which is
perfect
um we at Instinct removed and we had
higher faculties put in our place in
their place and if we would study these
and gain an understanding your
self-image would automatically start to
improve
you have perception the will
reason
imagination memory and intuition
those six faculties
will give you the ability to create your
own environment see we're totally
disoriented in our environment we're all
the other little creatures are
completely at home and theirs and we're
we're disoriented in Earth because we
can create our own but we don't know
that
school doesn't teach us that
school is more interested in
in the development of your intellect
than in the development of awareness
um
like
a person doesn't earn a hundred thousand
dollars a year because they want a
hundred a year they earn 100 a year
because they're not aware of how to earn
a hundred a month
awareness is really the key and when we
become aware of who we are and what
we've got working for us
you know marvelous things start to
happen to us
and that's really what happened to me
I never went back to school
um
I
I built a very successful company that
operates all over the world
um
I didn't do myself
I have tremendous team of people I've
got a just an absolute Genius of a
business partner a a woman who's an
attorney I mentioned to you before you
should have her on some time you she
you'd be fascinated with her she's that
interesting but
it was a group of people we've attracted
a phenomenal group of people in our
company
and we're operating now in 91 countries
wow teaching this information
you know
it's
I don't know another company that
teaches what we teach
like I think
Tony Robbins has probably done more for
our industry than any individual the
secret has probably done more for it as
much as Tony has
um the movie
um
but there's I don't know anybody else
teaching what we're teaching
and what we're really doing is teaching
people how their mind functions and um
how to expand their understanding of how
it operates rule number three is know
that you matter with Brendan burchard
strive and serve
free from outcome
those who read any Eastern philosophies
or spiritual work you know whether it's
the bhagavita whether it's you know
Buddhism whether it is more ancient ways
of thinking was the idea was show up
work hard help other people but free
yourself from the expectation of the
outcome
this is hard because a lot of people
have mattered
but they didn't get the outcome they
thought
so they didn't integrate that they
mattered
does it make sense they're like I
thought if I did that for other people
I'd become famous
and so they don't feel like they
mattered because what they're focusing
on is did I become famous did not no
then I don't matter versus focusing on I
showed up and helped people
meaning if you're emphasizing the
perfect outcome versus engaging in the
process
you will rarely feel like you matter
your focus is on this thing that you
can't control or contribute to
and if there's no connection to the that
outcome in your mind you go well I guess
I didn't matter I guess it did all that
I did all that I didn't matter
I was talking with a mom recently
um she has a a daughter who just turned
22 years old
and for the first 21 years
of her daughter's life her daughter
liked her
and then her daughter turned 22. she
doesn't know why but all of a sudden at
22 this daughter no longer likes mom
and she feels like she doesn't matter
all of a sudden I said well did you feel
like you mattered five years ago she
goes yeah I said why well my daughter
liked me
I said so your sense of whether or not
you matter in life depends on whether or
not in this moment today someone
likes you and approves of you
you see how ridiculous that thinking is
so the process of being an amazing mom
for 21 years goes out the door I don't
matter because now my daughter don't
like me I did all that for nothing
focusing on an outcome and most outcomes
are immediate we forget that outcomes
are entirely changeable over a period of
time we lose perspective we zero in on
what's wrong today and we feel wrong
versus recognizing
this woman made incredible choices
throughout her life
to care for this daughter
she's she's got enough meaning and
mattering points to last five lifetimes
for parents who are disengaged and don't
care
this woman gave so much
but she never gave herself the gift of
feeling like she matters
why because people get too attached to
the outcomes of life
when you learn to show up and to serve
and to do it free from whether or not
the world gives you the exact outcome
you expected
you start to find more enjoyment in life
when you have more enjoyment in life you
start feeling like it matters
when you feel like you do everything it
doesn't turn out exact and purposeful
and perfect
now it feels like nothing you do matters
and when it feels like nothing you do
matters because you don't get the exact
outcome you want and that's your daily
reality no wonder you don't feel like
you matter
so this is why even the Buddha taught to
strive earnestly
meaning show up be intentional
renew your enthusiasm serve
but don't be so attached
to how they respond or to what you get
or to what level you get
you know people are always like how do
you Bernie you've been doing this career
a long time
you know do you ever compare yourself to
other people you know other people have
more likes or more views or whatever you
can talk to my team I don't think I've
ever spoken to my team like you know
someone else has more views than me I've
been doing this a long time since
literally the invention of Facebook like
listen I I've never had that
conversation I don't care
what I care about is consistently
releasing goodness to the world what
comes back to us sometimes it turns out
it comes back as a number one New York
Times bestselling book other times I
don't make the list sometimes I have a
video ma'am it really takes off other
times the one I think would be amazing
no one watched guess what
doesn't
make any difference to how I show up
I'm gonna show up I'm gonna serve I'm
gonna teach I'm going to coach I'm going
to ride because I find purpose and
meaning in that
and I'm free from the outcome
I'm also humble enough that I've read
enough spirituality in my life and
studied enough history I know
and this sounds terrible for some of you
and this is so hard for some of you and
I get it
but and it might even sound stoic and
meaning in stoicism to you that
decades from now Generations from now
the odds that anyone would remember me
is so tiny
and guess what
doesn't bother me at all
think about that
the odds I mean think about even now how
many people when you think back one two
and three generations
in your own family
do you know their names
maybe you go down the street and you
recognize some buildings and they got a
name on the building
maybe you got one or two or three
characters like that in your hometowns
but when you're going back generations
of people
feel I mean few people can even tell you
who invented look around your room you
probably can't even guess the name of
the people who invented the very things
all around you
you probably don't even know who
invented that they invented a thing
that's in your house like in your house
they invented it you don't even know who
invented it how it worked how they
contributed their whole life to create
that thing in your house you don't even
know
and so it's a very empowering thought
to recognize the transience of this
world and the more philosophy or
spirituality you understand it's like oh
okay it doesn't mean that there might be
multiple Dimensions or maybe you have
multiple lives or maybe there's an
all-knowing God and and you're earning
points to go up there
I don't know what your beliefs are
but what I do know is it's almost
empowering to recognize what matters is
here
now
me showing up and serving now I'm not
attached to the outcome Generations from
now nor am I attached to the outcome in
tomorrow's social media post
I am going to serve and show up and
enjoy now I'm going to bring some
goodness into the world now
and that feels incredible meaningfully
meaningful to me why because who decides
think about that do future Generations
decide five generations from now three
generations from now is that when you
when you're dead looking down from on
high floating on your cloud with your
blueberries and strawberries and the
angels floating around and you're
looking down and 300 years from now
someone says oh she really mattered you
finally now allow yourself to feel it
when are you gonna allow yourself to
feel it babe when 10 years from now
when the 22 year old daughter
kind of comes to when she's 30 and
realizes how important you were in her
life like when
when
if not now my friend also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is remove
limiting beliefs with Mel Robbins Angie
why is it so easy to fill out limiting
beliefs but almost paralyzing to figure
out an alternative think this not that
how many of you are having trouble with
this it's very easy to see where you
doubt yourself
but it's super hard to come up with the
alternative thought that you're going to
substitute
well the reason why it's hard is because
you actually believe these thoughts
and these thoughts have become patterns
and they've become habits and they've
become so uh prevalent in your life that
they're almost like the co-host
of your life
um you know if you think about it you
are the star of your life but if the
supporting actor is a limiting belief
that constantly tells you that you're
not good enough or that you're not
worthy or that you'll never succeed then
it's no wonder that you believe it
because the co-star of your life is your
limiting beliefs and so it's not
easy
to
change your limiting beliefs but it is
simple
and it begins with you identifying them
and then substituting them so the most
uh I think effective way of beginning
the process of teaching yourself how to
identify a limiting belief and then come
up with your own
substitute positive belief as a way to
change the negative pattern in your mind
is to use the power of objectivity
so write down all your limiting beliefs
I'm going to go through this in detail
in just a second write down all your
learning English I'm not worthy I'm not
good enough nothing works out for me
nobody's gonna love me whatever the
it is that you think that's that's
bringing you down and then you can ask
yourself this what would Mel say
if Mel was sitting here across from me
what would Mel say
another thing you can do you can write
the opposite of what you're thinking
and you may not believe it it's okay
because what we're doing is training you
in a new pattern and one of the things
that Angie asked is she wanted to know
what were my limiting beliefs so
yesterday we sent out this workbook the
best decade ever toolkit it's in your
email if you go to the Facebook group
best decade ever with Mel Robbins it's
also listed on the files you'll find the
download for this check your junk email
if you didn't get it but
um so my limiting beliefs
so I want to have the number one talk
show of the decade
and the number one talk show of the
decade right now seems to be Ellen and
so it's interesting because a lot of my
limiting beliefs I think are provoked by
the fact that I'm the newcomer in a
space that I have huge dreams of making
a market and dominating so one of my
limiting belief is someone's already
done it how many of you have that one
my dream has already been done
so
my substitute thought because this feels
kind of true doesn't it
somebody's already done it
and then my substitute thought the Think
This Not That is well they haven't done
it my way yet
it hasn't been done by me yet
do you see what I mean so somebody else
has done it okay I get it it hasn't been
done by me yet
it's it'll never happen
it'll never happen how many of you have
that limiting belief it'll never happen
my substitute belief it hasn't happened
yet
so I'm acknowledging that it hasn't
happened but I'm adding on the yet
as a way to keep my mind in the positive
uh it didn't happen last time so it's
not going to happen this time
how many of you have that one
yep
this is what I say I wasn't ready then
I'm ready now
you know because it didn't happen last
time because I didn't know everything I
know now I'm ready now
uh I don't deserve it how many of you
have this limiting belief I don't
deserve it
my thought is if I work hard I'll earn
it
do you see that so it flips from a
statement where I'm bashing my
self-worth I don't deserve it to a
statement about
putting in the effort if I work hard
I'll earn it
oh I've got this story that I'm the Bad
News Bears
that I'm literally like the person with
the worst equipment and I'm the underdog
and I'm underfunded and
why does it have to be so hard and why
does it seem so much easier for
everybody else blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah and I flip that into I love
being underestimated and I love being
the undergo
in a very weird way as much as it
exhausts me it also empowers me
um oh here's a here's a specific
limiting belief
in a compete with that
compete with Ellen
um
especially when she's been at it for 20
years she has the budget of God and an
army of people that are supporting her I
mean there was something she did
announced yesterday on social media that
I'm so like uh of course and I was so
jealous she announced a partnership with
Starbucks where she's encouraging people
to pay for somebody's coffee using the
Starbucks app behind them in line
um and then take a video of it and
upload it they're gonna bring him on the
show and I was like oh will I ever get
there will I ever get the good cool
stuff like that and the answer is yeah
she proves it's possible
and also I can take the 10 years and be
like and in 20 years
I won't even recognize the cool stuff
I'll be able to do if I put in the work
so take that jealousy or somebody else
or whatever and say it proves it's
possible now put in the work
um so those are some of my limiting
beliefs and that's how you can do it and
by the way if you can't do that exercise
successfully on your own Post in the
Facebook group and tell people this is
your limiting belief can somebody help
you come up with a substitute positive
belief so that you can think this not
that ask somebody in your life to help
you
um and then what you do is when you find
yourself going down the route of that
negative thought it'll never happen
you're gonna five four three two one use
the five second rule to interrupt the
negative belief and then you are going
to insert the positive belief it hasn't
happened yet rule number five is invest
in yourself with said Guru
[Applause]
did you fall in love with your
neighborhood girl anytime
no
okay
suppose you are 16 years of age and
there's a very pretty girl in the next
door
do you have to focus on him
[Applause]
do you need a commitment
no you have interest
so you committed your focused your every
damn thing you freaked
so you need some interest
if you get interested in something
focus on that thing isn't it whatever
that thing is
but most people
do not know how to find any interest in
life unless they're hormone fired
this is like
just an evolutionary issue
see
every other creature
is only interested in that which is
either its survival or its reproductive
that's about it it's not interested in
anything else a bird an animal a monkey
what are they interested in something to
eat or maybe mating beyond that they
have no other interest because these two
things are chemically fired hunger is
chemically fired
hormones are chemistry
so this is a certain level of existence
animal existence is like that
you cannot blame them that's how they
are
but for you
a certain Evolution happens
not a small amount
not a small amount of evolution
though
today scientists say
[Music]
between you and the chimpanzee
the DNA difference is only 1.23 percent
but one point two three percent of what
what they're talking about is from an
amoeba to a chimpanzee
if it is 98
.77 percent
[Applause]
the 1.3 percent
more
that's not a small thing
I don't really know how they calculate
this one point two three percent but
when you look at some people it looks
like very real
yeah
but when you look at some other people
you cannot believe you cannot believe
that human beings were Apes
yes there's a lot of argument about it
it cannot be
both look like that but anyway
it's a small difference but a huge
difference
so if you
allow this one point two three percent
to operate within you
you will see you are not chemically
fired towards what you want and what you
don't want
why in every spiritual process anywhere
in the world
one thing that seems to be commonly
there is not because we are against food
some amount of denial of food simply
because we don't want to be chemically
ruled
brahmacharya staying away from food is
not because we want to deny something we
don't want to fall into that
category that we become an animal that
we are everything that we want is
chemically fired
we want what we want consciously without
the influence of our chemistry
this is why certain days of the month
not eating this is why many other
practices
fundamentally we don't want to fall into
the animal category because animal
category means not something bad it is
just a complete compulsive cyclical
process
now we are looking at
liberation
if you are in a cyclical process that
you're going around in circles there's
no question of any Liberation isn't it a
circle is a trap
yes or no
is it circular trap
if we make the circle large enough most
people won't know they're going in a
circle they keep going round and round
and thinking they're going somewhere
that is what going in circles means that
means you're not getting anywhere
we know if our longings and our focus
and our direction of life is chemically
fired either by hunger or hormones
we know that we will not get anywhere
this we figured out
because of that we are saying how we
create an interest and a focus and an
involvement in something which is not
chemically fired desire
if you have to engage people like this
or if you have to engage yourself like
this
you need uh some octane
going within you
if there is no enough energy
you cannot do this
because Focus takes energy
if you want to focus on something
what you need is not
some concentration camp mind
you need energy
with age energy comes down a bit if your
identity just remains physical
the energy that you had in the body at
16 you will not have it at 30.
you have to invest in your intellect
your intelligence your Consciousness
then only you can remain energetic if
you just invest in your body as you age
without knowing what's happening
now I'm doing this because this will
also go
unless you invest in other
if you just invest in the body as the
physical energy recedes you will see you
lose shape and form and become like that
you have to invest in other things which
does not need physical support
then you will see you can be whatever
age and still be vibrantly energetic
because your energy is not of the body
if you invest in something else whatever
your age you will remain energetic
so you must develop some interest in the
yoga then you don't have to focus you
will be focused and rule number six the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is forgive with Brian Tracy the
greatest human goal is peace of mind and
the greatest obstacle to peace of mind
is anger and blame aimed at other people
in order to eliminate anger and blame
you have to learn to forgive and there
are four people that you need to forgive
if you're really serious about changing
your life and learning how to live in
the present
the first people you have to forgive are
your parents living or dead you must
absolutely forgive them for every
mistake they ever made in bringing you
up at the very least you should be
grateful to them for giving you life
they got you here if you're happy to be
alive you can forgive them for
everything else
never complain about them again many of
my seminar participants have phoned or
visited their parents after the seminar
and told them that they forgive them for
everything and for every mistake they
ever made bringing them up
often this simple Act of courage and
character on your part has had the
profound effect on their relationship
with their mother or father from that
day onward they become good friends with
their parents which then lasted for the
rest of their lives together
on the other hand by not forgiving your
parents you remain forever a child
you block your own chance to grow up and
become a fully functioning adult you
continue to see yourself as a victim of
your parents a victim of your childhood
and even worse you keep your negative
feelings of inferiority and anger alive
inside yourself
if your parents die without your having
forgiven them it can bother you for the
rest of your life
the second persons you must forgive are
the people from your marriages or
relationships that didn't work out
these Intimate Relationships can be so
intense and so threatening to your
feelings of self-esteem and self-worth
that you can become angry and
unforgiving toward these people for
years
but remember you were at least partially
responsible for the relationships in
your life that didn't work out have the
personal strength and integrity to say
those magic words I am responsible and
then think of ways that you were
responsible for the relationship rather
thinking of reasons why the other person
is to blame
forgive the other person and let him or
her go
say these words
I forgive him or her for everything and
I wish him or her well
each time you repeat this the negative
emotion attached to the memory will
diminish almost like turning down the
heat on a pot it gets cooler and cooler
and soon it will be gone forever
many of my seminar graduates have found
that the letter is the key to putting a
bad relationship behind them forever
this is a powerful technique that I
learned many years ago and that can free
you from feelings of anger and
resentment almost instantly it can
liberate you from the negativity of a
past relationship in a matter of seconds
here's how it works
you what you do is you sit down and you
write the other person a letter of
forgiveness this letter consists of
three parts
first you say I forgive you for
everything you ever did that hurt me
second you write out a description or
list of every single thing that you're
still angry about some people write
several pages in this point in this part
what you did what you said what you
didn't do and so on they get it all on
paper and third you end the letter with
these words I wish you well
you then take the letter to the mailbox
and drop it in or if you're using email
and I prefer to do it on paper if you're
using email press send
at that moment you'll feel a huge sense
of relief and you'll be free at last by
the way don't worry about how the other
person might react this is not your
concern your goal is to free yourself
it's to regain your peace of mind and to
get on with a wonderful life that lies
ahead of you
now the third person you must forgive is
everyone else in your life who has ever
hurt you in any way let them go forgive
every boss every business partner friend
or crook or betrayer who has ever caused
you grief of any kind clean the Slate
and forgive and forget wipe away each of
their names and wipe the images off by
just saying whenever you think of them I
forgive him or her for everything and I
wish them well I forgive him for
everything and I wish them well you just
repeat this statement every time you
think of the other person or situation
until the negative emotions actually
disappear the most amazing darn thing
again when you start to say it initially
when you think of the other person and
they make you mad you won't see it much
of a reaction but as you keep saying it
I forgive them and wish them well I
forgive them and wish them well your
temperature goes down and down and down
and like a fire with no fuel it finally
goes cold and all the emotion is gone
the fourth and final person you have to
forgive is yourself
you must absolutely forgive yourself for
every silly senseless Wicked brainless
thoughtless or cruel thing that you've
ever done or said
stop carrying these past mistakes around
with you that was then and this is now
think of it this way when you did those
things in the past that you still feel
badly about you were not the person that
you are today at that time you were a
different person you were younger and
less experienced you were not your true
self as you are today you were an
immature version of the person that you
have become with experience so stop
beating yourself up for something that
occurred in the past something that a
different person did not you and
something that you cannot change
just say the words I forgive myself for
every mistake I ever made I am a
thoroughly good person and I'm going to
have a wonderful future
even better you can add the words I love
myself unconditionally
when you love yourself unconditionally
you let yourself go now whenever you
think of that past event or situation or
person that you heard or did something
untoward to just repeat
I forgive myself completely and then
get on with your life
focus on the future rather than the past
and don't look back look at where you're
going rather than where you've been
and finally if you did something that
hurt someone and you still feel badly
about it you can go to that person or
write and apologize just tell the person
you're sorry for what you did or said
whatever his or her reaction positive or
negative it doesn't matter
the very Act of repentance of expressing
regret will set you free
when you see people who are Noble in
spite of their suffering it is ennobling
it is uplifting right like really it is
and
um and it's been striking to me too
people want to be encouraged in that
direction I mean part of the reason that
my lecture is I would say have been
successful to the degree that they have
been is because people find them
encouraging and that actually seems to
work like it seems to be positive
because it is good news well it seems to
be I mean it isn't necessarily the case
that that would be the case you know
because it could have been that I would
have said encouraging things to people
there's more to you than meets the eye
and you're capable of more than you're
demanding of yourself and you know if
you took on your responsibility and face
the things that you're trying to avoid
that your life would be richer and
better and for you and for everyone
around you and the result of that could
have been that thousands of people would
come to me and say you know I gave that
a pretty good shot and it your advice is
really awful and everything is well
seriously like I took on that
responsibility it just bloody crushed me
and I'm way worse off than I was before
and everything's gone to hell around me
and like thanks a lot buddy and that and
that it's not like that's a completely
incomprehensible possibility but that
doesn't seem to be what happens is what
generally happens is that young people
in particular but not only come to me
and say look I've been trying to take on
more responsibility and to face the
things I've been avoiding and everything
is way better it's like okay well isn't
that something yeah I know something
well then you ask yourself well what's
the limit of that because that's the
religious question fundamentally is well
if you took on all the responsibility
you couldn't take on
and you faced everything that you needed
to face
what would you be like who would you be
and how would the world transform around
you and well if if the partial answer is
well if I do that a little bit things
get a fair bit better then the next
question might be well
what if you did that completely
and I don't think that's possible in
some sense right it's like you know
Perfection is a horizon that always
recedes but it isn't obvious to me
what the upper limit of that is and
certainly we do see people I mean Saints
race
who kind of pushed the limit and the
miraculous things happen around them
maybe in the literal sense and if not in
the literal sense close enough you know
for all intents and purposes and so
that's heartening I mean I
tear myself apart about this in many
ways because I think
perhaps it's possible to take on too
much responsibility and to crush
yourself as a consequence maybe that's a
sin of Pride who knows it's certainly
possible but my experience so far has
been that
when you see people bear their suffering
nobly
there's nothing in that but good
not something and then when you see
people take on more responsibility and
decide that they're going to aim up and
and
confront their suffering honestly and
forthrightly that their lives get better
and the lives of people around them get
better too
and so it's that's very strange as well
because it also means that the pathway
to less suffering
is through suffering
right and that's kind of that would be
hopeful if the world was constituted
that way it's like well there's
suffering how do you make it worse run
away
how do you make it better confront it
yeah but it's suffering it's like yeah
but it's there there it is it's right
there it's a precondition for existence
or something like that and it's like you
have something important to do as well
and you confront it and that's the
pathway to transcending it we had a
Thanksgiving where literally we had no
food and and we wouldn't have starved
but we weren't gonna have a Thanksgiving
dinner and uh there was a knock at the
door and that knock changed my life
because it was someone who delivered
food for us it was just a delivery man
the person who actually sent it that
didn't acknowledge who they were and the
man said this is just a gift for you and
your family my father didn't react very
well to it at the time
um didn't want charity but a necessity
took it in and I just remember at that
time thinking to myself
why is it that my father worked so hard
because he did work he wasn't unemployed
and yet here we are with no money on
Thanksgiving not even for food and it's
just my whole life had been that way and
I just I couldn't understand why we were
living on the other side of the tracks I
lived in what I thought was a rich
Community it was actually a middle class
Community lower middle class but
everybody else we live right next to the
railroad tracks quite literally and
everyone seemed like living a different
lifestyle and I couldn't understand and
my father I felt was as good as their
fathers as a person why did we have such
lack why was there such scarcity why did
they have so much abundance in us not
have any
and I really didn't have the answer
until I sat in that room with Jim Rohn
and he asked a question he said you know
what does it really take to do well
financially what does it take to have
real economic abundance and he said you
must bring value to the marketplace I'll
never forget and I thought what the hell
is he talking about value to the
marketplace
and he made it very clear that we all
have value in our own Souls but that's
not what we get paid for we also don't
get paid for effort we don't get paid
for our time we get paid to find a way
to add value and the question he asked
at the time was how is it possible that
some people earned twice as much money
as you do or four times or five times or
ten times as much money in the same
amount of time
and he said the answer is because they
found a way to add more value that is
the secret to abundance do more for
others than anyone else on Earth and if
you can do that you can build a brand
you can build a company you can build a
life you can build friendships that are
Beyond Compare and so that simple little
philosophy was really simple and he went
a little deeper he was very specific he
said you know if you look at it I
remember at the time he said if you work
for McDonald's in those days he said you
make 250 an hour
I remember he said you know somebody's
working making 250 now and they're
barely surviving today working
McDonald's you make eight dollars an
hour by contrast a little inflation but
this is 1977. and he said so why do
these people make so little and somebody
that he gave the example back then of
the gentleman who was the head of Disney
and he's made 52 million dollars in the
same year
one person's making 250 an hour somebody
just makes 52 million
is that how is that possible isn't that
fair isn't that unfair
and I remember at the time in pausing
and saying well anybody can learn within
an hour how to really do the numbers and
use a cash register in fact today you
don't even know the numbers you just
push a button with a picture on it right
so anybody can do that it's not being
disrespectful so there's not a lot of
added value in fact soon robotics will
probably take most of that over because
it's it's not something that expands the
human spirit it's not a complex task
that makes us expand or grow and offer
something
but he said you know the guy that
figured out how to turn Disney around
with having trouble it's worth 52
million because he's bringing joy and
happiness and love and laughter to
millions and millions of people so if
you help millions of people you're gonna
do well
in the Bible it says if you wish to
become great learn to become the servant
of many
which as Jim used to say is you know
that means there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be great but greatness comes
from serving a large number of people or
at a deep level of one of the two and so
you look at it today and today the story
is the same you work at McDonald's it's
eight dollars an hour and I just got
finished writing a book where I
interviewed 50 of the most successful
Financial people on Earth that started
with nothing and you look at a guy last
year David Tepper was the highest paid
hedge fund guy he got paid 3.5 billion
dollars last year now that looks like
incredibly unjust experience you know
it's insane it's insane to think that
that man's gonna make 3.5 and someone
else is going to make 15 000 a year at
eight dollars an hour basically how how
could you justify that well if you find
a way to add more value you can earn
more and you can be abundant he figured
a way to get a 40 return for people in a
world where most people are putting
their money in a savings account getting
33 basis points one-third of one percent
if you got people one percent
opportunity be having 300 more value but
he's adding 12 000 more value for his
investors these people have taken their
money and they're able to do things for
their families for their businesses for
the causes they care about because he's
growing it at a multiplied level because
he developed this incredible set of
skills and how did he do it the way Jim
Rohn teaches he learned to work harder
on himself he learned to master skills
no one else had that could add value to
others so introducing you to Jim Rohn in
abundance I just want to Mark out that
you can earn 10 times more 20 times more
100 times more in the same amount of
time if you work harder on yourself than
anything else if you find a way to do
more for others than anyone else and
then it goes beyond money
then it goes to understanding abundance
as an emotion like love
like Joy
it's the most amazing thing the more of
it that we give the more of it we
experience inside the beautiful thing
about monk life is half the day is self
and half the day is service that's how
you're taught to live okay so the
morning hours are for you to fill
yourself it's almost like putting on
mental emotional and physical armor like
that's what a morning routine is odd
days are tiring our days are busy our
days are draining well guess what if you
didn't put your armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when my morning routine is at
its best I feel protected I know exactly
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened I feel weak and so for me the
morning routine as I get strategic about
it there's two principles you have to
know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally before hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you're full hungry you'll feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise the brain only learns by
only we only see reality based on
pattern recognition I memorize your face
now I know Lewis and if the pattern
matches I know but if you're creating a
future
and you're not clear on that future and
you want all these things but you
haven't
addressed all those circuits and
behaviors and emotions and chemicals of
the past you won't recognize the pattern
you'll walk right past the relationship
you'll never see it so so I think that
there's the preparation for the
relationship
the overcoming
and overcoming and overcoming and
overcoming and overcoming and becoming
all of a sudden now says I am worthy and
the universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving so when you're
worthy to receive it's not going to be
on match.com when you're looking at body
parts and whatever else this is going to
be like
energy wow like that came out of nowhere
because
when you're in survival
and you're in separation and you're in
lack and you're forcing and controlling
and trying to predict outcomes your
matter trying to change matter and of
course it's going to take time for this
to happen because you're creating a
three-dimensional reality and everything
in three-dimensional reality it takes
time
but when you're creating from the heart
with a coherent brain and a coherent
harm and you got that 5G Wi-Fi signal
it's it's not like you go anywhere now
the experiences are coming to you're
drawing the event to you so so we spend
a lot of time
bonding with our future emotionally I
have colleagues of mine who look at our
our data on oxytocin and they're like uh
listen oxytocin levels go up during uh
you know when I'm in a relationship the
honeymoon stage of relationship and a
monogamy is created because of those
chemicals or a female mammal is bonding
with our Offspring that's exactly right
I want our people our students to bond
and fall in love with their future just
like they do with somebody else and when
you're bonded to your future
no person no circumstance no thing is
going to remove you from it so then if
you fall from grace during the day
then the next question is what person
what circumstance caused me to
disconnect from my love in the future
and let me rehearse in my mind if I have
that same circumstance how I'm going to
overcome it open your eyes and be in the
initiation of life and stay in that
place and just know that your future is
going to happen so so
being able to activate the heart and
breathe in there and get the body out of
survival and start working with it like
it feels safe enough to create once
energy makes it here you're going to get
some really good ideas you're going to
see things you never thought of seeing
you're going to feel things you never
thought you'd feel and the the images
that you're creating what are they doing
the thoughts that your cream they're
making more of those chemicals and now
you're feeling more of the feeling of
your future before it happens you're
you're giving your body a sampling a
taste of the future before it's happened
keep doing that enough times and that
feeling is going to become very familiar
to you there was a a researcher out of
Yale University that uh in the 1940s
that was studying electromagnetic fields
around living organisms and in 1940s in
at Yale University nobody was doing this
and he was a vitalist he wanted to
understand the Unseen fields around
living organisms
so he started studying eggs
all kinds of eggs chicken eggs swallow
eggs reptile eggs snake eggs salamander
eggs all kinds of eggs
and he was using a magnetometer and what
he found was what a hundred percent of
the time
no matter what a he measured the
positive charge was always at the head
and the negative charge was always at
the tail well if you have positive
charge on one end the negative charge on
the other end you got a external
electromagnetic field called the
magnetic field that's a magnet right
what happens with human beings
is every thought has a frequency every
thought produces a chemical so if you
keep obsessing about your lack your lack
of finances your lack of time your lack
of energy
and those thoughts I don't have this I
don't need this what are the chemicals
you're feeding your body you're taking
thought it's producing a frequency and
that frequency in the form of chemistry
is storing that thought emotionally
right in your second Center you feel
guilty you feel unhappy the moment you
feel unhappy then you generate more
thoughts equal to that feeling which
makes more chemicals and you keep taking
energy from the brain and storing it in
the body
you react to people in your life and you
feel anger frustration whether it's
traffic the news whatever it is
parents parents whatever girl what
you're drawing from this field
this electromagnetic field you're
tapping that resource
and you're making chemistry out of it
and the field shrinks so now
by doing that and living in survival
the body no longer is a magnet so now
you have very little energy in the brain
in fact five percent of the energy is in
the brain
the 95 is stored in the body now the
body's been conditioned emotionally so a
lot of energy in the body very little in
the brain I talk to so many smart
fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids and they're right out
of college they're in their entry-level
jobs and I'll ask them how is it going
and they'll say
I think I'm gonna quit
and I'm like why they say to me I'm not
making an impact I'm like you know
you've been here eight months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
Millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was Mutual
or they're quitting
because they're not making an impact or
they're not finding the thing they're
looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love
a job you find Joy from is not something
you discover it's not like I Found Love
here it is I found a job I love that's
not how it works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
Joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that Joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't see is the
mountain
this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is this entire generation
has an institutionalized sense of
impatience and do they have the patience
to go on the journey to maintain love to
feel fulfilled or do they just quit and
on to the next dump it onto the next
ghost and on to the next and by the way
ghosting
means the lack of skill to have a
confrontation
you date somebody for six months eight
months
and then just stop replying
just delete them from everything
now for the person who's doing the
ghosting oh that's certainly easier than
a confrontation but the person on the
receiving end of the ghosting it's like
there's a death there's suddenly shunned
there's Panic they call out they're
worrying they call out their word they
think it's you they think it's them do
you have any idea the destruction that
we reap on people by ghosting them
and then because there's the lack of
social skills to call out and ask for
help they internalize and it makes them
feel awful to the point at the worst
they will kill themselves slightly one
level down they'll get depressed but the
lowest level that we can hope for is
they will go through life and I'm not
talking about ghosting I'm talking an
entire generation that if we don't fix
this we'll go through life where
everything's just fine my friendships
are fine my work is fine you know same
old same old nothing's ever amazing
and the scavenger hunt continues
and then you go to the fourth
observation the most egregious of all of
them
environment
we're taking a generation that has lower
self-esteem we're taking a generation
that has a lack of coping mechanisms to
deal with stress we're dealing with a
generation that wants all those things
fixed immediately and we're placing them
in work environments that values money
more than people
do you know that most of the business
philosophies most of the business
theories that we Embrace and see as
standard today are not standard there
are theories left over from the 80s and
90s
the concept of shareholder Supremacy was
a theory proposed in the late 1970s it
was popularized in the 80s and 90s
the concept of using mass layoffs to
balance the books did not exist in the
United States prior to the 1980s
it did not exist
it became popular in the 80s and 90s
the 80s and 90s were boom years
anyone could make money relative peace a
Kinder gentler Cold War and so all of
the business theories that were put
forth were very very selfish and all
about enriching ourselves
and they worked for those times but
these times are different these are not
peaceful times
these are not boom years this is there's
globalization on the internet which has
now made everything vastly more
complicated and those theories do not
work anymore worse they're having side
effects
it's really bad
because what we do is we destroy
corporate cultures
the idea of using mass layoffs can you
imagine sending someone home and saying
I'm sorry
I can no longer provide for our family
because the company missed its arbitrary
projections this year
that's what we're doing that's like a
coach prioritizing the needs of the fans
over the needs of the players hoping to
build a great team
it doesn't work
we dismantled things like the
glass-steagall Act glass-steagall was
passed after the Great Depression to
prevent another Great Depression from
happening it was dismantled in the 80s
and the 90s in the name of a prophet
okay do you know how many stock market
crashes we had between the Great
Depression and the dismantling of
glass-steagall
the answer is
zero
and since they dismantled glass-steagall
we had 87 the.com crash 2008. we've had
three stock market crashes because we've
moved the safety mechanisms that prevent
stock market crashes from happening all
in the name of individual advancement
and profit and these are the corporate
cultures we've built
corporate cultures that value numbers
over people
and they are not standard business
practices they are new and they are
broken and they are dangerous and we're
asking a young wonderful ambitious
amazing generation that needs us to work
in these environments
whether we like it or not
we have to take responsibility for that
bad hand that you've been dealt
it is up to the companies to create an
environment in which you can build your
self-confidence
it is up to the companies to create an
environment
in which you can learn coping mechanisms
and learn how to build strong close
relationships with people with whom you
work that you will eventually love and
sacrifice to see that they gain
it is in these environments that we will
learn the patience and the hard work
that it takes to find fulfillment in our
lives to find a sense of purpose a sense
of joy
yes it's all fine and good that my
generation and older Generations say to
you things like well you're the Future
Leaders we're the leaders now
we're the ones in control of the
corporate environments now
and we're making your lives worse
I don't want you to jump from job to job
to job to job you will never find what
you're looking for it's not a scavenger
hunt I don't want you to go from
relationship to relationship to
relationship what I want you to do is
stand up and demand that the places in
which you work lead you properly
nobody wants to wake up in the morning
and be managed we want to wake up in the
morning and be led and we have a total
leadership crisis in America politics is
just the mirror reflection we get the
politicians we deserve
We're The Divided ones we're the selfish
ones we're the broken ones we're the
ones who would sooner sacrifice somebody
else so that we may gain it's us
and until we're willing to do the hard
work of repairing the world around us
our country our politics our businesses
will not fix be the change you want to
see in the world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
not as much as the government and big
business I think it's entrepreneurs it's
us we're going to solve all the world's
problems because we see a problem and we
want to fix it we want to solve it
that's what we do that's the most
exciting part of being an entrepreneur
is that you're not waking up and driving
to some job that you hate where the work
you're doing does not matter has no
meaning and instead you get to do
something that is actually going to
touch somebody's life and that is
Meaningful to you right you get the pick
you get to decide you get to choose and
we're trying to make the world a better
place we're going to make money doing it
too but Mission first purpose first and
then making money along the way in
service of others and it's in that
combination of what you love doing with
what brings value to other people that
you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough right it's like have
you had a hard time managing yourself
have you had a hard time sticking to
your routines and keeping to your
motivation and staying strong and the
things that you say you're going to do
like self-management self-leadership is
hard enough now we're going to go off
and lead other people as well and where
do we learn about leadership we don't go
to school for this we don't have
programs we don't probably have great
mentors to help us if you had jobs in
the past or maybe you're at a job right
now you probably don't have the greatest
leaders around you most people suck at
it but it doesn't have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and can people
ask me what's my definition my
definition of leadership it's I want
people to win more than I want them to
win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Carmichael video again maybe you
end up watching all my videos and we end
up being Partners on some future
business who knows you know I've even
seen you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have have you ever heard the
expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
you know and hopefully that's our goal
for life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring
we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks it's more that you know you
don't have the skill set we don't have
the skill sets at the beginning to know
how to even find the right person let
alone manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work for overloaded with
work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right so familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time it takes more time than
it frees up because you have to train
them you have to listen to them you have
to care for them you have to answer
their questions if you treat them like a
robot or a monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring and firing are you
going to be massively frustrated and
overwhelmed and a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck in that cycle
where has this happened to you you hire
somebody you know looks great on paper
you're so excited for it to go and then
it doesn't work out a couple months
later and then you decide you know what
I'm just gonna do it all myself right I
know I can get it done I'm just gonna do
it on myself does that happen to you
[Music]
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you have a big mission it's just
it's just you cool
go for it but if you've got a big
mission then it needs to be team and
that becomes a skill set that you have
to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that and it's
surprising how often you can find things
that support them and support you not
all the time I remember having one guy
in my team who his dream was to be a
baker
like well I I don't have an interest in
opening up a bake shop right but
ultimately you should you should leave
us and go do your passion because
because I can't help you inside of this
job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about so I gave him
till the end of the year if it was you
know summer give them to the end of the
year to okay you're as of the end of the
year you you're out and you have to go
find a job I love you but you have to go
find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and is actually
squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know you had to go and move on it was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn uh copywriting or
they want to learn how to come up with
good titles or they want to learn
better communication skills or they want
to learn they have their lists of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that some kind of
program some project something that can
also bring value to the company then
let's do it because when people are
working on the things that they feel
like they're growing in and they're
learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your XO
business strategy hat on it's it's great
this is how Karma becomes practical if
somebody's engaged and they feel like
they're learning and they're growing and
they're improving you're going to get
the best of them versus you have to feel
bored and stuck and learning nothing new
right that's what most people do in
their jobs and honestly the bar for
leadership is so low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody like a
normal human being and actually have a
little bit of care and compassion and
curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point
to then be able to say hey no I want I
want this person to have come out of my
organization whether that's in a month
or year 10 years from now a better human
because they were with us and it's
totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people and you want
to see them win and you're responsible
for making sure that they get pushed
outside their comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
a huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart
and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to commit to winning in life check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there get clear on what you
want what do you want make it super
clear you can't just want a better life
what does that look like get super clear
on what it is that you are going after
write it down one sentence